well we should probably address the
biggest news since kovin our good friend
our brother in arms Joe Rogan Simon
Spotify yeah now we knew what's coming
mmm we know it was coming
a little bird tell us a little bit I
mean Joe Rogan but we know it's coming
and then it shocked the world when it
did happen yeah and what's fighting me
is watch people speculate how much got
paid I mean but I know the real number
yeah so far off he's gonna be fine
they're so far off but he and I'm so
proud of him money's not an issue and we
said them but I been rich for a long
time but this is different
well we price sharing it's personal with
me and bring them a video of my son yeah
tell them to buy a boat well pay my
household i seduce or moon texas here's
the proposal
you gonna buy each of us a house and we
need yachts
well [ __ ] dude I wouldn't Brian
doesn't do in the fight campaign you've
never paid to see 25 years I can't get
it I can't get my beak wet a little girl
can't weave wet my beak who to friends
yoo-hoo how many friends you have like
Brennan and Brian [ __ ] you know what
selfish [ __ ] yeah I think it I think
it's a good move for a number of reasons
I think it's not good how YouTube has a
monopoly on things and it's frightening
just do you monetize but they have a
monopoly on things and when a company
like that goes we don't like the way
Brian said that we're gonna do monetize
that whoa that's not what we signed up
for originally yeah we don't like the
way Brendan's talking about Kovac
because maybe didn't have these facts so
we're gonna monetize that or a shadow
bandit or put it in the algorithm so it
doesn't pop up dude we just signed up
for this who's dictating well I think
what happens with anybody's dictate when
you have a lot of power like whether
it's Google whether it's Apple whether
it's YouTube you feel a responsibility
to try to make the world a better place
you just do
and again you're gonna have your you're
gonna have your biases and so they have
these conversations in that board but
where do you stop it at that's the big
world Brian and Brennan can't cuss
anymore if they do or do monetize it
well but it we're adults show yeah but
you you this is that's what then we so
we can't cuss and say certain stuff on
YouTube because you're worried kids are
gonna see it although kids to get access
to this have to
parent or the kid has they accept accept
that click on accessor right even now
there's a tool that we have to do to say
not for kids
upload again this is stuck but then
there's the shows on Hulu and Amazon it
still isn't you but it's a new play it
said no but it's relatively new in in
other words like the space is always
changing and I I just think as you get
that big and that powerful there are
these conversations you have there are a
lot of conversations you're allowed
propaganda of the the Russian hoax and
the scammers and you know and all this
political stuff which is in fact checked
and well or you allow Isis videos and
ice prop again and stuff like that for a
while it's like we're we're you gonna
tell the line that it's and why would
you point your gun at a comedy show it's
a good question but but I would say but
in this at my point all this is well now
by Rogan jump in a Spotify and we've
been on I think we've been on Spotify
but they had video till Rowan came on
board and I think they're gonna launch
their video portion of in September I
think in September I think by then the
year they have video but by September
Brogan will be over there exclusively
but now that there's more than one
player in town now if you don't like
somewhere you can play for another team
which is our advantage I think it's best
that's the greatest thing about the
marketplace if you let people compete it
creates a very equal playing field and I
appreciate that because it's very scary
it scares me when any any time you have
a five companies controlling all the
monopoly will happily that's not it but
it's like u2 goes hey man Brendon Brian
when you guys joke about suck and Brian
off we don't like that yeah so we don't
want on our station or our network all
right well we can go Spotify said we can
do whatever we want so when you're over
there that's cool go over there guys
alright cool man but the promise of
where you have nowhere to go
and we rely on YouTube and then they go
well we don't like the way Brian said
that when you're not gonna do [ __ ] Brian
you know I can do anything we can troll
the narrative you're not gonna do
anything
so here's what else undo I'm gonna do
monetize it because I don't like what
you said but then we're gonna run our
ass so we make sure we get paid but
you're not gonna get paid yeah even
though you share a video your hard work
of seven years every week twice
we haven't missed a single week in seven
years but listen we're gonna get the ad
revenue that's what do you monetize
that's what a monopolies are you got
your goddamn mind oh yeah your mind it's
like you it's like you said what are we
supposed to do about it right now if
there's not a player like Spotify but
that's what happens is is another
company comes in and sees that there's a
demand there's a need sees there's a
deficit sees that the employees are not
happy but you're right I mean at this
point there is there is one player in
town it's a little bit like being a
fighter for the UFC if you don't like it
you know we'll see you over there mm-hmm
right
and so I think that we are this is a
little bit of what's happened to us
inadvertently it's bound to happen well
how about our issues with Apple where we
played some video which I don't remember
some music and then okay cool you guys
use that song so now we're gonna do
where make it impossible for anybody to
find your podcast whoa dude mm-hmm what
can you give us a warning or now let us
and try calling somebody and talking
about it well thank God for chin and
calling it Cass media who have contacts
to Apple and they're like it got this
and then you know then some somebody did
it and took it down yeah what do you
mean took it down who gave you that
right dude yeah because we used a hip
hop song and it was also fair use cuz
we're talking about it we just played a
part it was in well yeah yeah well III
like that but again you can't run a
business like that man which is when you
have creatives on your platform one of
the reasons you know I don't have a
nine-to-five because we don't abide by
the same rules as most people we started
this because we you don't want to work
for somebody I don't want to work for
somebody you want to talk to HR right
here what's your problem but Apple is
like no well that's not the way we work
all right dude then we go somewhere else
man and we there's a lot of places we
can go well not right now but there will
be hopefully there is yeah there is and
I do think it's very good for all of us
and for everyone included in this space
and here's the other thing
what Rogen did being such a pioneer and
the godfather of podcasting at his level
it's not a Howard Stern thing where
Howard Stern got really really big and
was free for everybody and then he sold
I liked how
but then he sold out what the serious
they got paid $29.99 to listen to him
from now on
and there's no video there's nothing
that's the only waking listen to Howard
Stern why stop with now Howard I'm
[ __ ] yeah I'm serious I'm gonna pay
that every month I don't have it anymore
right Spotify is free tell listen Jill
really it's me free is it free yes with
ads though so if your premium with
nothing changes yeah
nothing it's free nothing changes all
you got to do is download the app and
the video I'm sure the in figure has to
be great they have all this money
nothing changes but instead of the
YouTube says Spotify it's free for
everybody so you can't say he sold out
because he's not behind a paywall now if
he went over there I was like hey it's
$9.99 a month
y'all you like dude you chase the money
you just doing that for the money yeah
no he's doing it for the freedom I think
he's not being such a brilliant move by
Spotify such a brilliant they're their
stock went up a billion dollars after
they made the road a billion bucks one
upload day they made a lot of money so
smart and it's so smart and they're
they're gonna take over the podcasting
space because I'll tell you when you do
run in these issues with Apple and with
YouTube all due respect but you know
when when you have a couple of people
controlling that the information highway
which is a huge problem and Spotify
comes in and says go that's very
attractive that's very attractive to it
but every creative yeah for every
creative yeah yeah man I mean you know
the thing about YouTube is just YouTube
don't have any skill there no data
there's none of that it's based off the
creative minds on so for Logan Paul
right okay he started doing when he's
younger it was kind of a kiddie show
he's making his video stuff like that
well Logan Paul grew up he's a very very
successful mix whatever 30 million
dollars a year he's at the top of the
charts on YouTube
well psych is a huge at Logan Paul and
the creative content puts out he's
getting the money from them and their
long Paul goes I want start podcasts
logan paul's whatever 23 year old man
cuz i like porno stars I'd love to talk
to a porno star so YouTube goes cool
we're gonna do monetize then take you
down that's not your brand the [ __ ] are
you talking about that's the man's grown
up because you picture him over here
if he decides to do this that's his
right that related to him yep you
can't decide that's well Dave you come
when did you two become so puritanical
with the politics the Russian the
Russian probe stuff like that via
Facebook look out Facebook crash like a
[ __ ] when we found out they were
giving away info and allowing this
Russian propaganda to go down and break
the election do all that [ __ ] feel like
hold up how did they get all this info
the next whistle again I actually gave
them the info excuse me
the people don't trust Facebook well
that's the thing like I do think that
you have an overwhelming number of
people Trump is such a polarizing figure
just such a polarizing anybody who
stands for anything is but but but you
know with YouTube and with Google and we
know that the people running these
companies tend to lean in one direction
politically yes they just do but that's
wrestling applying their progressive but
it's very difficult but see when you get
a lot of power it's very hard not to
mold the world in your image and how's
that work out for you though then then
well they would say great YouTube you
want to say great and dictate and be
monetized yeah but their stuff just show
you've ever had of all time with I'm
gonna go play ball over here no no it's
too late dude you made your bet yeah
well there will be a migration if people
have an option you know but you I won't
be the food these are such powerful huge
companies I don't live it I think it's a
little bit like saying hey hurts go [ __ ]
yourself sometimes but but YouTube's
gonna say yeah I mean yes but I do think
I do think that big companies fall big
companies lose ground all the time it's
as things change as they get outdated as
their model gets outdated as they you
know there are people that say they get
fed up they get fed up and I don't think
I took I just can't fathom why if you're
on YouTube and mice my son has YouTube
it's with the kids account you can't see
fire the kid Ian see me talking [ __ ] and
do our thing or and see my stand-up or
anything we've ever didn't see that if
you can't he doesn't have access that
stuff but if we're not in the kids
category I understand we're labeled a
kid show yeah did you go watch your P's
and Q's can be some talking about
[ __ ] my mom and stack in my hand I
can't have you do that Brian right kids
are gonna watch now with the kids don't
stack a nubby we know you don't stack
no and you know that's wrong but and I
apologize for having that in the
forefront of my brain all the time I
know and that's fine but no you're not
going to Denver but that's your right
that's my right when I copy works the
altitude I got a dirty looking sweet
that's all yeah I don't stack my mom and
my dad's where everybody drinks are
flowing and AHA that surf and turf comes
the high altitudes you're not there but
then you're I can get there bro yeah but
by that time by that time I'll get there
but by that time I'm dude don't talk
about [ __ ] like that time you got
some gift others sack my aunt in my bias
you're my mom is in I know that we have
a good neck shawl we have a connection
and by that family good day you gotta
have brothers and on and cousins cousins
and I'm kind of your dad well they are
bad here well I'm happen why don't you
sit up bad here Oh Brian's our dad let
me say and I go like this I go hey yo no
I go hey hey watch your P's and Q's I
remember that you remember when I went
to Denver ten months ago yeah I want you
to call me Dad things happen understand
yeah let me step daddy now yeah I'm your
stepdad Oh your step daddy and I won't I
won't answer to Brian I love you I
called the Jazz TV kiss call me oh my
dad I kiss my son my lips and a Bob slap
you right now no I don't want that in my
in my head cuz I'm having a good day and
it gave me Ronna about YouTube and Apple
right now and I'm also going to pick up
my s-works
levo specialized bike after this dude
it's the best bike in the world it's a
big day for this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]